I was actually texting with bill when I was, uh, you know,
I was going through my recent problems. You know what,
when they were coming blood, no gun in the mouth. No, when he was,
he started spewing blood a little trouble, you know,
they call me Yani nuts on the show because they feel like, Oh,
I gotta put nets before. Cause I keep almost passing out. Yes, yes.
We'll have those nets out. November 9th grandma's seat there.
We'll put the nuts out emoji behind me in case I fall my set. Yeah. He'll beat.
Yeah. So I told pillows. I passed, you know, and comedy connection.
I canceled my whole weekend. I got off stage. I was doing call your wife.
And I was still struggling with this when I was doing a Mohican son at a comics
and I spoke to bill and it was just so nice to speak to somebody older and like,
you know, anytime he goes to these line. Yeah. I'm not lying.
I don't know what that is. It means you're older.
Wiser been there ahead in the career. Let's go further. Let's be clear.
Kip moves tickets. barely showing up bananas.
Yeah, I I've. I sold it out once. It hadn't been, uh, since I put down the wig,
I haven't been asked back.
I got asked to give money back to cops in San Francisco. That's how bad I did.
Oh, I got sent home. I got sent home, uh,
punchline Sacramento. I just gave bill come on. And
they're really impressed with my new house. I'm like, yeah. Yeah.
Sunday it happening. We're going to wait to sit in your home.
How would you like to get on a plane right after your show? I got one of those.
I got demoted from headliner down to feature act. The first time I, uh,
headlined at the Trop and Vegas
on the check was seeing, I flew her out to see me my big headline. Oh yeah.
Oh yeah. But this is early on, right? Like in your,
where you're still in your twenties. But at that point, um, no, I was about 30.
I think when that happened, I was definitely, that was 30.
Whenever I feel they hit to the chest that felt like in your thirties, twenties,
you can shake them, but you'll get young running back.
You still got young legs and your thirties, that's when they start slinging.
Like when the lions go after that one, Buffalo, that's slowing them down.
That's kind of what was going on there.
Me and Angelo tried to do a theater with more recent Panos in Philadelphia and
we sold about 50 tickets and like a place that fits 700. I was there,
I did that. So they moved us to the bar area. Wow.
So we did the show at the bar area,
which I'm glad I would rather have done that than do it in the theater.
So they made the right move, but it hurt. It hurt stunk. It's yeah.
I feel like I'm going to SAC, uh,
Sacramento punchline this weekend and tickets are low,
but it's one of those things where it's like tough ticket. It's a tough,
and it's just like, you know what I, this is where, you know,
I'll work on my stuff. I'll just try to kill every hour and that's,
and just promote as much as I can. I mean, what can I do? You know,
make sure you have a car. Yeah.
I didn't have a car and I was trying to save money and I just was at the comedy
condo and there was a McDonald's right near it. It was one of those dirty,
McDonald's nothing worse than a dirty McDonald's and just people, uh,
using out there. So I was just, yeah, it was a what's third. So I actually,
I don't think I was that upset when they sent me home. Probably I did it.
I did a tour, uh, uh, you know, this is back during the, uh,
when Dane blew up on MySpace and all of a sudden people saw the power of social
media. Um, then all these agents, it was so.
They started trying like, well,
you got 3000 and he's got 15,000 and you got 4,000.
We put you all together, you know, you're going to sell out an 800 seat theater.
And it just didn't. It was just like, it's just like, it's like,
you're a country singer, you're doing death metal and you juggle,
like they didn't have like a through line. Right, right.
So they tried to put me Geraldo and a young Mike Birbiglia
together. And I, I should have known it was a bad idea.
Cause we were trying to think of a name for the tour.
We couldn't remember Geraldo rest his soul. He goes,
how about two men and a baby? And I was like, that could work. And we could,
we could do the poster and we actually should have done that.
But I forget what it was. Uh,
I forget what we ended up even calling it. And it just,
it just didn't work because Greg and I were similar enough
that we sorta had the same little fan base. Right.
And then Mike was way over there and it just, it just was not, you know,
there's gotta be a through line to the show other than this three guys talking
into a mic. So yeah. Yeah.
That's funny that they were just trying to combine your,
they're trying to add your numbers together. Oh yeah, no, don't do anything.
Don't don't build the act. Don't don't go that route. Let's get the money now,
burn them out and then ride the next horse. Shoot these in the head.